writing no mark I puts the water can be
identified over to an unmarked to avoid
uncertainty over 70 hurricanes that's
cool too 386 to be at six decoration of
result for the UK Parliament via action
for the constituency of harmonic sector
on the eligible electorate 70,000 for
100 yet that's the 7010 with the votes
forward we're 20 1153 that's why 1152
the ballot box was fifty thousand eight
hundred and sixty-three that's 50 its
explore an invalid votes was 186 to be
at six the percentage started was there
for 70 to my main six percent
ie Martin Fox as a deputy returning
officer for from on-site Barone's and
Stefan see hereby declare that at the
election the number of votes for each
candidate was as follows quiet dawn SDLP
social democratic and liberal party 3732
2732 home ultra universal party
twenty-three thousand six hundred and
yet that's 2 360 get the other new shell
champion 23,000 70 80
Green Party 700 idiot Wow Alliance Party
658 65 it I declare that Tom Elliott is
returned to serve compartment with
Ramona on central constituency
thank you very much stick this has been
a combined effort I want to thank all
those who assist the first day I want to
pay tribute to mr. box and all the staff
of the elected office your openness in
action and the last day I'll ever forget
what day we right now but I have to say
whatever I contacted the office they
were almost Bible for diabetic so thank
you very much second issue is to all who
supported unhealthy first thing could I
pay tribute to my family through by my
side all the time also
thank dr. gonna just show you what you
can do with a resume never at least I'm
Democratic Unionist Party the
traditional union of spice usual the
victim sector the light orders under D
can I say from right across slave from
rain across the spectrum the [ __ ] votes
came from right across the community and
I thank those people to realize we need
representation also altered would be
reversibly if I didn't a fight you
should I kill dinner who just regret the
fe on my web on fair play and for that
thank you very much
right there that is gentlemen this
constituency of permanence Esperon the
most Western abstention see in the
United Kingdom is not a green
I intend to represent how does who I
intend to represent I say to you I give
this I give this victory to the people
who thought on fought for democracy and
will not democracy to dance a 70th
anniversary of PDA with the Second World
War Mozambican see that we can stick
down here today of whatever willing a
representation wins without it is
optimal verse 8 by give you on a show
ladies and gentlemen I won't represent
like when represent the people from
outside through I would represent them
in Westminster I will go and find a
welfare reform i was going final
taxation issues and i will do not in the
corner of westminster and then the
chambers of westminster ladies and
gentlemen this is a great victory no
monthly mega kingdom
not only really blue thank you very much
in support I at Madame has been immense
rain across the spectrum and I thank you
for this rate to disenfranchise summer
people they taking the the polling
station of radiation but thanks to those
people in my gosh of the mission a
casserole yes best wishes safe journey
home from outside throw those
representation